la batalla contra el hobbit 19 ha traído
una nueva amenaza para el medio ambiente
y la salud pública un informe de la
organización mundial de la salud señala
que decenas de miles de toneladas de
desechos de material médico que en algún
momento fueron utilizados para combatir
el coronavirus se acumulan en vertederos
y se convierten en un gran problema
descubrimos que el kobe 19 ha aumentado
la carga de residuos sanitarios en las
instalaciones hasta 10 veces los
volúmenes actuales y se considera que 2
de cada 3 instalaciones sanitarias en
los países menos desarrollados no tenían
un sistema para segregar o tratar de
forma segura los residuos el informe
señala que aproximadamente 87 mil
toneladas de equipos de protección
personal adquiridos entre marzo de 2020
y noviembre de 2021 terminarán en
desechos después de ser utilizados
además de contaminar el aire y el agua
de las comunidades que viven cerca de
los vertederos mal gestionados toneladas
de jeringas desechadas kits de pruebas
usados guantes y frascos de vacunas
exponen a múltiples riesgos a los
trabajadores sanitarios ante esto la
organización propone alguna solución
no utilizar guantes para la vacunación y
otras interacciones en las que los
guantes no sean necesarios utilizar
vidrio y otros envases más ecológicos y
aumentar el uso de artículos seguros
reutilizables en particular máscaras
seguras reutilizables para el público en
lugar de máscaras desechables el reporte
llega en un momento clave cuando el
sector sanitario enfrenta presiones para
reducir su huella de carbono y disminuir
la cantidad de desechos